ce big lebowski des frères coen le jude
se fait m'éclater dans les chiottes
pendant que chinois puis sur ce tapis
alors il va dire à ces photos bowling
sont plissés sur mon de tapis
guerre du vietnam
c'était pas mon tapis alors le tube
fâché le gros les mots ce qu'il faut
empêcher un tout neuf d'achat mais parce
que sa femme a été enlevée alors
redonnons 1 millions $ liée aux
ravisseurs les pays exigence à travers
la gueule alors il retourne au bowling
de walter qui jouent bas pendant shabbat
shabbat vietnam quand il ressort de la
voiture a disparu millions de dollars
donnant du coup le job avant la fin du
gros chien puis s'est chopé la voiture
du père qui veut son feuillage sa femme
ait pas de put alors day ou l'audio
d'yves uci les tranquilles dans son bain
mais il ya les nombrilistes débarquent
avec leur mare motive aussi habite avec
walter schels avait donc pour y exposer
sa bannière mais c'était pas la sienne
alors le vrai propriétaire du doubs il
va chez un producteur de porno des
tripes sur une walkyrie tous les
boulistes se fait casser la gueule par
le shériff pézenas avec walter hill
balance le grand les moustiques de son
fauteuil parce que le salon il a menti
depuis des années a à payer un mec qui
ferme sa gueule qui part ensemble et ça
finit captieux courbe celle où elle
raconte pas super super mais c'est trop
bien